make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and as
per our charter here on comics explain
i'm going to make you an expert in
comics in 30 minutes or less and in this
video we are going to be covering
the super soldier serum so we're going
to cover this in two different ways the
first
is that we are going to use the super
soldier serum as it exists in the main
marvel universe then the second thing
that we're going to do is cover the
super soldier serum as it exists in the
ultimate universe
and the reason why is because the marvel
cinematic universe is largely based off
the ultimate universe and i imagine a
lot of you guys are watching this
because of just the existence of the
super soldier serum in
the marvel cinematic universe plus
what's going on in falcon in the winter
soldier no spoilers so
uh an important thing to understand here
is that the super soldier serum
is not necessarily a serum one of the
things that's covered in captain america
comics number one back in way back
way way back is that the serum is only
part of the enhancement process right
it's also exposure to like different
forms of radiation that help to kind of
you know help to kind of develop the
serum or help the body ingest it and
then
enhance it properly so that's one of the
first things to lay out the important
thing to understand here is that as most
of you guys are aware
the super soldier serum as we know it
today which is to say
process under which a person is exposed
to the serum along with radiation
treatment uh to
to basically move them to the peak of
their potential originates back to
abraham erskine and steve rogers right
that abraham erskine was working on a
super soldier serum while he was in
germany the united states got word of it
they ended up sending nick fury and his
howling commandos to germany during
world war ii
they snatched up uh abraham ersky and
they brought him back to the states and
he basically began working on project
rebirth uh
the funny thing about this those guys
who are asking how it is that nick fury
could be in world war
ii and then in turn also exists in the
modern age he consumes something called
the infinity formula which is kind of a
variant of the super soldier serum but
it's basically a formula that keeps you
youthful eventually he lost it and
that's why he ended up aging up at a
rapid pace
that was revealed during the original
sin storyline but uh the important thing
here
is that steve rogers as he was you know
exposed to the super soldier serum the
way it was created by abraham erskine it
was the perfect variant right pure
unadulterated absolutely perfect and
it's the only time in the history of
comics
that's ever happened where the super
soldier serum actually worked as it was
intended to create the perfect man
beyond that you start getting into
various you know various attempts to
duplicate it
some of which have created individuals
vastly more powerful than steve rogers
uh captain america and others have
twisted people and screwed them up and
turned them into something that's just
kind of bonkers
so the the immediate attempt by the
federal government to duplicate the
super soldier serum that led to steve
rogers came in what was called the
300 soldiers right or however you want
to refer to it but basically the events
of like isaiah bradley right so the idea
that when captain america was fighting
during world war ii the united states
government secretly
uh started working on creating a new
super soldier serum
using the knowledge of a guy by the name
of wilford nagle and wilford nagel was
kind of one
half of the experiment but the whole
point behind this was it was an attempt
to
duplicate the serum of abraham erskine
which was incomplete because abraham
erskine had died shortly before that and
so they ended up grabbing 300 black
americans taking them off to a fake camp
in mississippi called camp cathcart and
then
essentially exposing them to different
doses of the super soldier serum and
different forms of radiation sometimes
the dose was too high and the radiation
was too extreme
and any combination thereof the result
is that only about uh only about five or
six guys
survived the whole process and isaiah
bradley ended up being the only person
who survived his experience after being
exposed to the super soldier
serum and the various issues that came
along with it and so following that you
go into what's called the black widow
program right now the black widow
program
is interesting black widow the the way
the project was done
was essentially designed to be russia's
version of the weapon x project
right so uh one of the things to
understand here in comics to kind of
sidetrack for a second that with the
avengers being formed in the united
states and the fact that the the cold
war was under
was had been going on for a while which
meant that not only did you have the
space race you had the superhero race
while the united states had the avengers
uh russia
ended up traveling around the entirety
of the country and snatching up anybody
that had powers
and those individuals who did have
powers were conscripted into what was
basically their winter guard program now
this was a fate that was actually
uh saved for colossus from charles
xavier so basically charles xavier the
x-men went to russia and rescued
colossus and kept him from being you
know
forced into russia's winter guard
program which is why he never actually
became part of the winter guard even
though he was supposed to they were
actively looking for him and trying to
ensnare him
but while they also had the front face
with the winter guard group and all that
kind of stuff what you also had was the
kgb
and the kgb was like russia's spy
organization which as i understand it is
something comparable to america's cia
and what they ended up doing was
creating their own weapon x program
weapon x was basically a a subsection of
what was called weapons plus in the
states which was a joint venture between
the canadian government and the united
states cia which basically allowed the
cia to
experiment on people overseas or at
least you know across the border without
having to be kept to the jurisdiction of
united states law the supreme court all
the stuff that goes with it and so while
we were doing that weapons plus had
weapon one which was secretly captain
america then you had weapon two three
four five six running all the way up to
ten
which was wolverine but when word had
reached the ears of the kgb that the
united states had successfully created
a super violent assassination weapon in
the form of wolverine it was not
necessarily like captain america but
something akin to him without any of the
the moral you know moral holdups uh they
started creating their own program and
so what you had was a woman by the name
of uh and i'm probably gonna butcher
this but it was uh ludmila kudrin i
think it's how you pronounce it uh i've
never been able to pronounce her name
correctly in all the years that i've
been reading comics i've never
pronounced her name right i feel like i
feel like i've always gotten it wrong
well i just kind of roll with it and i
don't really worry about it too much but
she created what was in effect a female
version of the super soldier serum that
was designed to basically complement the
estrogen in women's bodies and then
enhance their attributes this led to
black widow natasha romanov
along with the rest of the black widow
program right so that's where that comes
from but then following that you go into
you go into the sentry now the century
is a little bit of a murky situation
because where most everybody here was
exposed to the super soldier serum in
some form or fashion and it pushed them
to the peak of human potential
project century ended up turning robert
reynolds into what was in effect a god
more or less um not a god
in the traditional sense i mean he can
alter reality to some degree he can't
really do it on a universal scale though
so we those are the guys who are coming
from marvel comics and you know what i'm
talking about he's not really equivalent
to like the molecule man or franklin
richards those of you guys who are
coming from the marvel cinematic
universe he's not equivalent to like
thanos wielding the infinity gauntlet
right he's not really equal to that he's
exceedingly powerful
and if he had been in the marvel
cinematic universe with even a mere
measure of the power he has in the
comics he would have obliterated thanos
in no time flat right that fight would
have been over before it even started
but the reality of this is that
originally robert reynolds was a meth
head and he ended up discovering what
was basically this kind of experimental
serum that was called the golden century
serum and the idea was that it just
he thought it would get him high and so
he ended up taking the golden century
serum and then it basically ended up
giving him an insane amount of abilities
because technically the serum was a
thousand times more powerful than the
super soldier serum but the difference
here is the way the century draws his
powers
comes from essentially tapping into an
extra dimensional energy source and this
dimensional energy source
is essentially created or or developed
by being known as destroyer dark mass
and the the way this works is it's
almost like cyclops is optic beams where
cyclops opens his eyes and his eyes are
just a portal to a dimension of pure
energy
it's very similar to that robert
reynolds basically draws on an energy
source from an alternate dimension but
the way this works the way this this
kind of uh you know destroy your dark
mask concepts works is that whenever a
person is a host for that energy
and is able to use it that there is an
inherent creation of a counterbalance to
that that you can't have somebody using
all that power with no counter and that
counter balance comes in the formation
of
the void and so if robert reynolds
possesses all this godly power
and when he uses that power he becomes
the century in the same way that clark
can't become superman
then the counterbalance to that is the
void the dark persona the part of
himself that is just
evil and and malevolent and doesn't want
to do anything but destroy stuff
right so that's that's how those things
work really it was just kind of it was
it was invoking the notion of like gods
and
and monsters to a degree and different
things along those lines you do have a
few other involvements that go in there
right so like a modified version of the
super soldier serum that led to the
creation of power man luke cage but for
the most part the real meat and potatoes
of the super soldier serum as you guys
know it in marvel comics really comes by
way of the ultimate universe especially
when you look at the marvel cinematic
universe itself
so in the ultimate universe the entire
concept of the super soldier serum and a
lot of the superhero concepts that exist
in the ultimate universe are simplified
right it's just
it's it's much much easier to understand
the way this works is
you have the original super soldier
which was actually nick fury right so
the super soldier serum was created
uh nick fury was the test subject for it
and it worked but nick fury ended up
escaping and going underground but with
the serum working then it passed to
steve rogers and steve rogers became
captain america so that's a big
difference between the super soldier
serum as it exists in the ultimate
universe and the main marvel universe
but following that kind of continuing on
in the ultimate universe the attempts to
duplicate the super soldier serum
existed all the way up to the modern era
right so things like wolverine and the
attempt by canada's
government to create a new super soldier
resulted in them discovering the
existence of a mutant gene that if it
was activated would grant powers and so
when they tried to
try to to create a super soldier or make
a super soldier out of wolverine they
accidentally activated his latent mutant
gene which gave him a healing
factor then they bonded him with
adamantium and then he went forward as
wolverine in the ultimate universe but
following that you had things where like
steve rogers ended up coming across a
girl named gail richards and
back when he was fighting in world war
ii they were supposed to get married but
they didn't right i mean one he was you
know frozen in a block
of ice and you know she presumably
passed her in that time but she was
actually pregnant with his son and so
his son went forward and ended up
becoming the red skull
so because of the fact that he just
basically inherited steve rogers super
soldier serum in his blood when you look
at something like spider-man spider-man
was created in the ultimate universe as
a result of the attempt by norman
osborne
to create a new super soldier serum with
the odds formula and when speeder parker
was bitten by one of the test spiders he
became spider-man right so
it's a it's a very very simple process
when you look at the ultimate universe
in comparison to the main marvel
universe as far as how the super soldier
serum works and how it spreads and
impacts the various superhero
communities that are out there it's a
big takeaway from all of this with
regards to uh
to the the serum and this is a shorter
video that we normally do the the big
takeaway from all of this
is that the super soldier serum under
perfect ideal
circumstances will take what is a
regular man and
elevate him to the peak of human
potential it won't really give him
powers
it won't really give him you know the
ability to alter reality or read minds
or anything along those lines it'll just
basically push him to the absolute peak
of human potential steve rogers captain
america
is the perfect host for the super
soldier serum right he's the perfect
example and it cannot be duplicated
for whatever reason it can just never be
duplicated in comics people have tried
and nobody's ever succeeded instead all
the different and varying iterations of
the super soldier serum that came after
steve rogers have had a wide array of
different effects
everything from turning peter parker
into spider-man in the ultimate universe
to things like creating the the century
out of robert reynolds
in the main marvel universe right so
it's had all kinds of huge impacts that
exists out there and there's other
examples we haven't ran over every
single
example of uh those individuals who have
the super soldier serum we can if you
guys want we can just do it as like a
list style and just run over every
single person who has been exposed
to some variation of the super soldier
serum in marvel comics i think it's a
cool idea if you guys are interested in
that let me know and i'll make a video
about that uh but yeah guys uh any event
we're gonna go ahead and wrap this up uh
but if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you